[Música]
la economía en directo américa de france
24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
resultado jorge vamos a iniciar dándole
seguimiento a la crisis económica es
blanca que ha pasado en ese país bueno
lo último es que en esa nación el
suministro de combustible ahora va a ser
exclusivo para los servicios esenciales
la isla de 22 millones de habitantes
tienen dificultades para pagar las
importaciones esenciales de alimentos
medicinas y sobre todo el combustible
que mencionábamos la situación ahí es
tan grave raúl que las escuelas están
cerradas y los funcionarios de gobierno
fueron enviados a trabajar desde sus
casas para intentar ahorrar energía la
medida oficial estará vigente desde hoy
hasta el 10 de julio ordena que en sí
blanca sólo se va a suministrar
combustible a trenes y autobuses a los
servicios médicos y a los vehículos que
transporten alimentos en la capital
colombo se podrían observar ya vehículos
esperando las afueras de las gasolineras
y personas tomando los últimos autobuses
disponibles estas son algunas reacciones
de los ciudadanos
cómo puede una persona normal venir a
trabajar incluso en un servicio esencial
sin combustible para su transporte yo
trabajo el turismo si no puedo conseguir
combustible no puedo ir a trabajar los
autobuses no funcionan bien dicen que no
habrá autobuses para los viajes simples
hermanos
y vamos hasta el gigante asiático para
hablar de algo que hablamos son mucho en
el pasado en un acreedor presentó una
petición de liquidación contra
evergrande si de precisamente a finales
del año pasado para que mencionábamos
mucho este caso se hablaba así pero que
no iba a quebrar siguió arrastrar la
economía china si también se iba a
llevar consigo a todo el sector
inmobiliario de china pues bueno ahora
en la bolsa de hong kong en la que
cotiza de haber gran se reveló que hay
una denuncia en contra de esta empresa
de parte de la empresa tops ya en global
la petición de liquidación contra la
endeudada inmobiliaria está relacionada
con una obligación financiera que
asciende a imagínate 862 millones de
dólares y program dijo que se opondrá
enérgicamente a ésta y que espera que no
tenga un impacto sobre sus planes de
reestructuración el juicio contra
evergrande será el próximo 31 de agosto
y ever brand se hizo visible como
recordaremos en 2021 luego de reconocer
que tenía problemas para pagar una deuda
de 300.000 millones de dólares y
despertó temores de un colapso que
arrastraría a la economía china bueno y
dejamos a un lado hacia para venirnos a
nuestra región de américa latina que
pasó ayer con el término de la huelga de
los transportistas jorge esto en perú
bueno la buena noticia es que concluyó
sin incidentes sin violencia
precisamente y con reducido bloqueo de
carreteras a nivel nacional entre los
reclamos de los transportistas en perú
está la restitución del transporte de
mercancías como un servicio público la
reducción y el precio del diesel y la
regulación de peajes tras la revisión de
los contratos con algunas concesionarias
los temores de una huelga indefinida
hicieron que muchos comercios sobre
abastecieran para evitar quedarse sin
insumos el gobierno de pedro castillo
agotó los esfuerzos durante el fin de
semana para llegar a consensos con los
transportistas
levantar la medida en el cusco principal
destino turístico de perú las empresas
que ofrecen el transporte de tren hacia
machu picchu suspendieron sus servicios
también este lunes como una medida de
precaución así como la ruta que se
dirige hacia la ciudad de puno
escuchamos y que decían los
transportistas y a propósito la huelga
va a continuar el próximo lunes el perú
en estos momentos encuentran una gran
crisis política económica y social ya es
por eso que el transporte pesado como
gremio organizado que está ha levantado
la voz de protesta porque cuando
nosotros no somos políticos somos
transportistas somos empresarios
pequeños que vivimos el día a día y
estamos recontra quebrados ahorita por
la mala economía que está llevando el
país seguimos en el sur de américa jorge
le pregunto los detalles que hay sobre
la delegación estadounidense de visita
en venezuela bueno la idea de esta
reunión según dijeron es continuar las
conversaciones con caracas que se
iniciaron en marzo
eeuu ya renovó una licencia para que las
empresas petroleras incluida chevron
puedan seguir realizando mantenimientos
básicos a los pozos que operan de manera
conjunta con la petrolera venezolana
pereza nicolás maduro el presidente
venezuela también reaccionó a la mención
del presidente francés emmanuel macrón
sobre la posición de venezuela en el
mercado petrolero instando a que se
permita a venezuela inyectar crudo en el
mercado mundial para bajar los precios
del petróleo afectados por la guerra en
un gran escuchamos que desea y nicolás
maduro
macro en el presidente de francia hoy
tuvo una expresión hay que reincorporar
a venezuela y airam al mercado petrolero
yo diría occidental porque nosotros
estamos en el mercado petrolero yo le
diría al presidente de macrón presidente
macro
venezuela está lista para recibir a
todas las empresas francesas que quieran
venir a producir petróleo y gas para el
mercado europeo para el mercado mundial
bien medidos cuando quieran el camino
está hecho estamos preparados
una apertura en venezuela ya lo sabremos
jorge indicadores bueno empezamos con
las acciones europeas que estuvieron
lideradas por los valores vinculados a
las materias primas y los fabricantes de
automóviles después de que china
relajará su mandato de 40.000 kobe 19 y
en asia también entraron en territorio
positivo impulsada precisamente por esta
decisión de china de suavizar las
cuarentenas
jorge le gustaba madrid encanta bueno
vamos lamadrid ahí está nuestra enviada
especial estela herrera para la cumbre
de la otan vamos a hablar de eso con
ella
[Música]